[Music]
what's 71 percent of the Earth's surface
being covered in water it's no surprise
there are hidden gems located beneath
the surface from buried treasures UFOs
and entire cities you never know what
you'll find when you take a dive if
you're new to our channel don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up because today we'll be
sharing 10 most amazing things ever
found underwater just wait until you see
the photos of a sunken pirate city in
the Caribbean we promise it'll shock you
the lost Egyptian city in the year 2000
French archaeologists discovered an
entire Egyptian city 30 feet below the
Mediterranean Sea known as her a Klien
the city was a vibrant and bustling town
judging by the artifacts that were found
numerous statues of ancient Pharaoh's
pieces of artwork coins made of gold
lead and bronze and a fleet of ships
were discovered on the floor of the sea
it's unknown how the city managed to get
submerged beneath the water many believe
the rising of the sea could have
swallowed the entire city or the town
was possibly the victim of a natural
disaster such as a tidal wave or a
massive earthquake a hidden River
scientists have discovered a river that
follows along the bottom of the Black
Sea deep-sea divers explored the area
and found that the river has its own
waterfalls trees and leaves the river's
layers of dense water were formed when
sinkholes became filled with saltwater
the water moves along the ocean floor at
a rate of a half a mile per day it's
like a whole new world below the surface
of the sea if this river were on land it
would be the sixth largest river in the
world would you like to take a deep-sea
adventure to visit this river let us
know in the comments section down below
the Pyramid of Yonaguni a scuba
instructor dived off the coast of the
Japanese island Yonaguni in 1996 and
what he discovered was shocking hidden
below the surface was a perfectly
designed pyramid complete with steps
columns and a human face carved inside
the rocks in the following years experts
visited the underwater site and
concluded it had been man made in
approximately 10,000 BC it's been said
that the pyramid sunk into the ocean
after a massive earthquake the Lion City
in 1959 the ancient Chinese city known
as Lion City was flooded on purpose to
make room for an
hydroelectric power station but then the
government forgot about the city for
years
it wasn't until 2001 when the government
decided to rediscover the city through
diving expeditions Lion City dates back
to 621 AD and even after being submerged
below water for years it's still in
pristine condition divers discovered
that many of the structures carvings and
lion statues were still preserved and
the water had protected it from natural
erosion deep in the Baltic Sea
Swedish divers uncovered a bizarre
discovery on the floor of the pelvic
scene measuring 60 metres in diameter
and standing on tall pillars divers
believed it may have been a UFO the
diving team also noticed a staircase
with a hole leading into the interior of
the object and they also claimed their
electrical equipment stopped working as
soon as they swam closer to the object
we may never know if it's an actual
alien spacecraft but we wouldn't be
surprised if it was do you think it's
possible a UFO crashed into the Baltic
Sea and sunk down deep into the water
let us know what you think down below
sunken pirate City at Port Royal the
city of Port Royal Jamaica was inhabited
by unruly pirates up until 1692 a huge
earthquake and tsunami shook the wet and
Sandy foundation of the town and sunk it
into the Caribbean excavations have
recovered historical documents preserved
food and various buildings the city had
plans to turn the sunken city into a
tourist destination but for now it has
practically been abandoned would you
travel to Jamaica to see this pirate
city the Titanic this legendary ship
sank in the North Atlantic Ocean on the
morning of April 15 1912 after colliding
with an iceberg during its maiden voyage
the RMS Titanic sank to the bottom of
the ocean the wreckage wasn't found
until 1985 when the ship was discovered
12,000 400 feet below the surface of the
water over time the ship's roof have
caved in and the decks have weakened but
it's still amazing to see photos of this
legendary ship that's a part of world
history underwater circles a scuba diver
stumbled upon a pretty interesting site
off the coast of Japan these geometric
sand patterns were found 80 feet below
sea level and they're six feet in
diameter known as the mystery circle
many people believe the pattern was
created by a UFO but it was later can
firm that it was actually the work of
Japanese puffer fish the fish create the
pattern during their mating ritual as a
way to protect their eggs pretty
interesting don't you think
a whale washes ashore there's no telling
what will wash ashore on any given day
due to natural causes or after being hit
by a boat propeller massive whales have
made their way on shore beachgoers are
usually perplexed and a little afraid to
see these thirteen thousand pound
creatures so close to land some whales
and sharks will even beach themselves
mass strandings of marine mammals date
back to the days of Aristotle have you
ever seen a beached animal leave your
reply down below in the comment section
and you might even get a reply from us
underwater sculpture park the world's
first underwater sculpture park was
created in the Caribbean Sea just west
of Grenada designed by British sculptor
Jason de Kerr Taylor the submerged
museum is open for public viewing
sculptures include statues of people
from the local community including a
circle of children holding hands a man
working at his desk with the typewriter
and a life-size man riding a bicycle
would you like to visit this Caribbean
attraction one day which of these
underwater findings did you love the
most
leave us a comment and the most original
reply will get pinned to our channel if
you'd like to see more videos like this
one don't forget to subscribe and hit
the thumbs up button thanks for watching
[Music]